and today we're going to talk about who
are some future guests you would like to
have on the show I'll go first salt
poppy oh I love him how about Big Ben
tag him please he doesn't look athletic
but he just destroys me I can do that
he's really good he's making pretty okay
boxers look like
I want him to fight Jay Paul I'm gonna
be a pretty good fight I think so I'll
talk to him here and there oh you do
yeah yeah he's really cool he grew up on
us he brought us about JK on David oh
dude say that earlier what bring him on
yeah we're gonna talk about two minutes
about this guy you're like yeah
everybody tag him but you're like
already in direct communication yeah
okay I forgot he's a man I am autistic
so yeah okay